[Music]
it is Thursday and Thursday means that
it's time for ponies throwback Thursday
monologue the year was 2011
[Laughter]
yeah I gotta tell you earlier reviews
for these spider-man musical are out
alright Los Angeles Times calls it an
artistic form of megalomania that's the
last thing the critic wrote before he
was killed by a falling spider-man
Charlie Sheen's big tour started this
weekend you know Charlie Sheen kind of
snapped he lost his mind he's gone on
tour right now cuz it's 2011 it's being
reported that during Charlie Sheen's
live show in Detroit hundreds of people
walked out of the theater yeah yeah you
know you're in trouble when people would
rather take their chances on the streets
of Detroit
Kayne West has been invited to the royal
wedding between Prince William and Kate
Middleton yeah apparently Kanye was
invited to serve as the royal pain in
the ass
good stuff I love this year I just can't
believe it's already 2011 you know and
and before beard glue was invented man
it's a great time to be alive isn't it
Andy sure is Conan
[Applause]
[Music]
there's Emily despite this we have a
professional show tonight star of the
highly anticipated that just has
completely failed
you